du jour vous le savez hier on a eu de
nouvelles de nouvelles de nouvelles de
l'enquête concernant la disparition du
petit Émile un cette histoire folle les
fouilles ont repris mais finalement ça
n'a rien donné ce petit garçon de 2 ans
et demi qui a disparu comme ça d'une
minute à l'autre qu'on a pas retrouvé
depuis 2 mois dans un village de où il y
a 14 maisons c'est ça 14 habitations
alors où se trouve le petit Emile est-il
encore en vie quel est l'ambiance dans
le village du vernis Gilles l'habitant
du village on avait déjà eu au téléphone
viens nous voir ce soir pour nous en
dire plus c'est une des premières fois
qu'un habitant s'exprime sur un plateau
elle a pas eu regardez et c'est vrai
qu'on a envie de de d'avoir encore de
l'espoir bien sûr pour la famille pour
le petit et c'est vrai que plus le temps
passe et plus on est inquiet petit
requin
depuis plus de 2 mois le petit Emile 2
ans et demi est introuvable il y a eu
des rebondissements aujourd'hui une
nouvelle fouille en cours à quelques
centaines de mètres de la maison des
grands-parents mais cette semaine dans
cette affaire qui bouleverse les
Français un nouvel espoir est apparu
nous vous rebondissements dans l'affaire
Émile les enquêteurs sont en train de
creuser sous la dalle d'une maison une
piste qui a été étudiée pour lever
quelques doutes mais qui a rapidement
été expédié par les enquêteurs mais
aujourd'hui l'absence d'éléments concret
et de garde à vue rendent sa disparition
mystérieuse alors où en est l'enquête
désormais incohérence ambiance secret à
un habitant du Verney se confie sur la
disparition des milles
merci Gilles d'être avec nous merci
beaucoup énormément d'incohérences
vraiment dans ce dossier vous habitez au
vernis depuis combien de temps j'ai
toujours à habiter là bon pour des
raisons professionnelles j'étais
expatriés maintenant que je suis à la
retraite je reste là-bas à plein temps
que vous connaissez donc l'ensemble des
habitants du village oui je connais très
bien le tout le village et le hameau du
haut Vernet les autres hameaux du
village alors connaissez bien entendu la
famille du petit Emile alors c'est pas
de je les connais parce qu'ils habitent
à Obernai c'est pas des gens que je
fréquente mais je les connais je les
vois toujours circuler en famille dans
le village alors on entend énormément de
choses sur cette famille Gilles oui
notamment et sur le grand-père sur les
parents absolument vous qui est au cœur
du village c'est très intéressant que
vous puissiez vous exprimer parce que on
a l'impression d'abord que cette famille
était repliée sur elle-même donc on se
dit qu'il y a des mystères des secrets
et puis on se dit que la dernière fois
que le petit Émile a été aperçu le
grand-père était peut-être à côté en
train de couper du bois est-ce que vous
qui connaissez très bien la famille vous
pensez que si on dit que potentiellement
il y a une piste familiale on est dans
la réalité ou est-ce que vous pensez
qu'on délire
et ben les enquêteurs font leur travail
et personne ne doit interférer quoi il
faut laisser les enquêteurs travailler
aujourd'hui bon il y a le ils ont
commencé à ratisser très large ça
remonte la pyramide de romanes comme on
l'a dit voilà et donc les choses je
pense qu'elles vont aller très vite
maintenant quoi il y avait cette
histoire l'histoire de la dalle dans
Cyril parler il y a déjà trois semaines
après la disparition on n'avait qu'à
commencer par cassé un morceau
aujourd'hui les enquêteurs sont allés
plus loin ils ont cassé toute la dalle
donc les choses avant c'est parce que
toutes les hypothèses qui ont été émises
non elles sont toutes elles
le rapace le loup le la personne qui
serait venue pour enlever le petit aussi
il faut savoir que c'est une malgré que
ça soit une départementale elle est pas
très bien entretenue quoi et donc on
sort on arrive à peine à se croiser
dessus et quelqu'un n'aurait pas pu
stationner il aurait gêné population
donc on aurait remarqué le véhicule et
arriver dans cette fameuse rue en bas de
la rue il y a un jardin il faut
contourner le jardin pour repartir donc
il faut faire deux ou trois manœuvres au
moins et donc quand on est dans un
hameau où il y a 7 ou 8 maisons
d'habiter est effectivement quand on
entend un bruit on relève la tête et on
aurait vu une voiture rouge bleu et mais
là on a aucun indice aujourd'hui il doit
y avoir un climat de suspicion terrible
dans ce hameau vous êtes peu nombreux
vous vous connaissez tous vous avez tous
été interrogés elle ressemble à quoi la
vie aujourd'hui au vernis mais la vie la
vie devient un peu plus pesante de de
jour en jour quoi parce que
effectivement on a cette suspension oui
bien sûr je parle avec les autres
c'est le sujet qu'on aborde en
permanence quoi vous avez envie de
savoir ce qui s'est passé voilà on a
envie de savoir parce que le souci c'est
que
on peut pas retrouver une sérénité tant
qu'on n'aura pas retrouvé quand on
n'aura pas l'issue de cette affaire
positive ou négative on espère tous les
villages a été interrogé par les
gendarmes
le hameau du haut Vernet tous les gens
qui étaient présents ont été interrogés
on a visité leur maison on a visité les
voitures des gens qui étaient là quoi
mais pour l'instant juste
un instant vous avez dit
on sent que l'enquête avance ça va aller
très vite
mais qu'est-ce qui me fait dire ça c'est
que le il y a eu il y a eu beaucoup de
gens d'interroger une fois deux fois
trois fois et donc et ben ces gens après
on les met de côté quoi et c'est cet
effet de pyramide
on peut pas on peut pas rentrer dans le
qui est un non
quête avance quoi
que vous voulez nous dire et que les
enquêteurs ont déterminé peut-être
aujourd'hui c'est pas du tout ce que je
dis je dis qu'on a il y avait des gens
présents on a interrogé les gens et
petit à petit et bien on les a éliminés
parce qu'il n'avait rien à voir avec
cette affaire et petit à petit l'enquête
remonte
quel est votre conviction à vous vous
mois de conviction moi je peux pas je
peux pas imaginer qu'on puisse faire en
tout cas c'est pas quelqu'un de
l'extérieur pour moi c'est pas quelqu'un
de l'extérieur on peut pas accéder au
Vernet
sans se faire remarquer on peut pas
l'enlever le loupe pendant le vélo non
plus
donc ça reste un mystère aujourd'hui un
mystère vous avez pas une intuition
ah non je veux pas je veux pas voir des
je veux pas voir d'intuition moi je
pense que je pense toujours que l'on
peut retrouver le petit quoi exactement
on espère mais c'est un mystère parce
que entre 17h17h15 dans cette fameuse
rue quoi et la rue bon c'est c'est pas
une rue c'est pas une rue de Paris quoi
le chasse-neige a du mal à passer donc
en haut de la rue il y a un four pour la
convivialité du village en plus on l'a
construit une belle halle donc ils
peuvent manger les pizzas sous l'ail et
en bas il y a la fontaine de la rue qui
est aussi conviviale il se retrouve pour
l'apéritif donc c'est c'est le lieu
convivial du hameau et donc
les gens ne se retrouvent là donc c'est
beaucoup de choses sur la famille vous
la connaissez la famille de loin est-ce
que vous avez été les voir d'ailleurs
depuis le drame est-ce que vous avez été
les voir en panique non j'ai pas été
alors bon moi j'aurais aimé que le ça
s'est pas fait quand tu as eu le
problème dans l'autre sens là moi
j'aurais aimé que la mairie demande aux
habitants du village qui le désiraient
quand ça tous pour soutenir la famille
ça n'a pas été fait je le regrette et
moi j'ai laissé la famille est déjà
assez accablée d'avoir perdu cet enfant
qu'on sait pas où il est quoi et donc je
les ai pas dérangé mais
bon c'est déjà on les a beaucoup
critiqué parce qu'ils allaient à la
messe à la messe à la terre mais moi je
préfère voir déjà avec leurs enfants qui
vont à la messe en latin plutôt que de
les voir derrière l'église à fumer des
pétards quoi voilà on en a dit beaucoup
de choses sur ces gens mais les enfants
sont bien élevés quoi dans le village ça
c'est courant ça alors voilà c'est ce
que je disais avant c'est une une petite
on va dire une ruelle quoi
qui fait le village donc c'est le centre
du village et donc là il y a pas de que
ça soit en haut dans le haut ou en bas
c'est pareil les enfants se promènent se
promènent seul oui c'est en dehors de la
de la route qui est qui est fréquentée
donc le les gens sont prudents c'est une
question à vous poser moi Gilles on
comprend pas parce qu'il y avait une
dalle de béton le rappel pour qui nous
rejoignent à des 19h56 il y a une dalle
de béton qui a été coulée le jour même
de la disparition des milles les
enquêteurs ils ont fouillé qu'une partie
de la dalle ils ont cassé qu'une partie
de la dalle les premiers jours on prend
pas et là maintenant donc deux mois
après deux mois et même deux mois et
demi après il commence ils ont cassé
toute la dalle
je comprends pas cette incohérence
comment ça se fait vous avez des infos
pas du tout non j'ai pas d'infos et eux
ben voilà ils vont peut-être je pense
qu'il voulait être sûr de ne pas avoir
raté quelque chose oui mais deux mois et
demi après
c'est beaucoup parce que la coïncidence
est quand même extrêmement troublante en
matière de fait divers on se dirait que
c'est pas possible autrement en plus il
y a eu des travaux un peu bizarre on se
demande pourquoi c'est dalle en
extension de bergerie comme ça est-ce
que quand vous avez eu vend des travaux
puis vend des fouilles là vous êtes dit
c'est peut-être la bonne piste j'ai donc
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que cette
maison en fait vient d'être vendue et
les gens avant d'y habiter vous voulez
faire des travaux pour une
agrandissement donc voilà pourquoi elle
a été elle a été agrandie quoi après bon
dans les films on peut voir certaines
choses que des gens qui sont prudents
dans la dans le cinéma mais moi je peux
pas imaginer vous la connaissez la
famille
je connais le grand-père
qui a qui a notre chalet dans le village
de l'autre côté du village d'accord il y
a énormément de choses aussi qui qui se
disent sur le sur le grand-père
des Mille vous le connaissez lui je le
connais de vue je le sais c'est pas une
personne que je fréquente d'accord le
maire du village il a été interrogé mais
le maire du village lui il a participé
il était dans le PC de gendarmerie
pendant les recherches donc voilà il est
au courant dans l'enquête vous vous avez
été interrogé non je parle le gendarmes
m'ont posé quatre questions mais c'était
savoir
où j'étais ce que si je connaissais la
famille comme nous ici quoi voilà pas
plus
le village du vernis est de nouveau
fermé aux visiteurs il avait été rouvert
c'est ça les nouveaux fermés pourquoi
parce que les enquêteurs en fait en font
un lieu
presque un sanctuaire un lieu clos il y
avait des touristes malgré beaucoup de
touristes qui venaient il y a une fête
notamment au des touristes en aurait pu
profiter pour se glisser ce qui a choqué
les habitants du village aussi je sais
pas si Gilles vous étiez choqué mais en
fait ils ont ils ont bouclé le village
parce que de plus en plus il pense que
la piste est interne au village je dis
pas un terme à la famille mais c'est
interne au village il c'est parmi les 10
15 habitations qu'on va trouver la
solution
le petit séparevé donc voilà la solution
elle est au village et après bon ce que
vous venez de dire c'est très important
pour nous quoi pour la vie du village on
a déjà eu le problème avec la Lufthansa
des badauds qui défilent toute la
journée quoi et qui roule très vite sur
nos petites routes quoi et ça bon je le
dis ce soir il faudrait c'est pas le
lieu de vie tu as le quoi bien sûr il
faudrait que les gens s'abstiennent de
devenir
que l'enquête aboutisse et après ça on
pourra recommencer
la vie
est présente parce que le moi quand je
descends de chez moi j'ai 2 km pour
aller au village bon je je descends à
pied je regarde toujours au bord de la
rivière parce que je ramasse les
champignons mais aujourd'hui je tourne
dans la tête de l'autre côté quoi je
j'envoie un peu j'avais une appréhension
j'ai l'impression voilà et il y a pas
que moi tout le monde donc c'est pour ça
qu'on espère que l'issue arrivera
rapidement et surtout que les les
curistes qui sont dessous entre deux
mains vont pas venir encore nous polluer
l'atmosphère et laisser
retrouver la sérénité
les enquêteurs se concentre forcément
sur les premières minutes de la
disparition de des milles il y a un
témoin qui dit l'avoir vu descendant et
un autre remontant pour qu'on comprenne
bien la configuration des lieux c'est où
est-ce qu'il a pu aller il y a cette
fameuse cabane comment vous expliquer
d'abord c'est Inco je pense quelqu'un
qui le dit qui dit qu'il est parti dans
un sens un autre dans l'autre et ensuite
où est-ce qu'il a pu aller d'après vous
alors pour le
le il y a deux personnes qui montaient
qui descendaient ils l'ont pas vu
exactement la même heure donc d'accord
donc il a plus volonté et après ben
après c'est le c'est le mystère puisque
les chiens s'arrêtent en bas là à la
fontaine c'est durant ces fameuses
minutes que le grand-père coupé du bois
c'est ça ça c'est ce qui est écrit dans
dans la presse je suis pas dans le
confidenté de le
défaut c'est que des enquêteurs quoi les
chiens s'arrêtent à la rivière c'est ça
qui est incroyable il s'arrête en bas de
la rue ben oui c'est ça et après ça
s'arrête en vacances c'était volatilisé
c'est ça voilà voilà vous avez dit le
mot comme si c'était volatilisé
aujourd'hui il y a pas d'explication
c'est un mystère c'est les enquêteurs
qui pourront nous donner parce que
personne ne peut comprendre ce qui s'est
passé vous croyez un enlèvement
non pour moi c'est impossible
l'enlèvement est impossible parce que on
peut pas on peut pas
la voiture interne
vous êtes d'ailleurs dans le village
personne ne parle
[Applaudissements]
à vous exprimer oui mais les gens bon
les gens se sont assez pudiques ils
n'aiment pas s'exprimer n'avait pas
s'exprimer en public voilà bon moi je
suis venu et je voulais bien faire
passer le message ce soir que les gens
nous laissent nous laissent tranquille
dans le village voilà
c'est devenu un spectacle c'est qu'il y
a plein de gens qui veulent venir voir
en touriste ce qui s'est passé là-bas et
essayer de jouer les les enquêteurs de
fortune et voilà et donc c'est vrai que
c'est insupportable pour les habitants
donc merci d'arrêter de voilà de devenir
donc là ça a été fermé mais bon quand
même c'est toujours je sais bien de le
dire comme ça au moins faudrait que vous
soyez libre de pouvoir faire les venus
tranquilles et qui est pas des des gens
qui viennent polluer votre votre
quotidien oui on dit que entre Le Vernet
et le haut Vernet il y a beaucoup de
secrets secrets de famille on a parlé
d'une d'une maison qui appartenait aux
grands-parents du petit qui avait été
brûlé il y a quelques années est-ce
qu'il y a de l'ours secrets qui pèse
dans le village donc il a pas de il n'y
a pas de secret ça bon
ce qui se passe c'est que quand vous
avez cru au Festival de Cannes quoi avec
le nombre de journalistes qui étaient
présents sur les lieux pendant la
recherche et donc
il faut qu'il trouve quelque chose à
dire alors il cherche effectivement la
la famille le l'arrière au grand-père
habité un peu plus un village où il y a
eu une maison qui a brûlé il y a il y a
quelques années il y a jamais eu d'issue
à cette histoire
donc voilà mais pour moi ça n'a ça n'a
aucun rapport quoi mais c'est une
coïncidence ce qui est ce qu'on retient
Gilles c'est que vous sentez que l'issue
en tout cas on sent l'enquête avance oui
bonjour ça colle que je sens que
l'enquête avance très bien et j'espère
que très bientôt
l'issue on espère on aura peut-être des
bonnes nouvelles parce que j'espère ce
qui compte c'est la vie du petit email
voilà voilà je pense beaucoup aux
parents qui marrant et aux parents et
aux grands-parents quoi est-ce que je
peux vous dire que ça doit être des
minutes et des jours insoutenables on se
met à leur place dans des comptes deux
mois et demi sans nouvelles de leur fils
merci en tout cas